if gonna face the business put out
content I put out content vaynermedia
puts out contact you both put out
content content content content content
the answer every question is more
content more content Sunday morning
NBA all-star Staples Center just been
networking business stuff here with our
Mountain Dew client kickstart gonna go
in see what's up then head to San
Francisco
he's such a good dude there's a guy
who's super convener doing all the
production stuff man
sup man just there we go
my god how are you going up
no no I'm chillin I'm just with my
clients oh how are you good good yeah
leave me to my sister right here
Christina
hi Christina how are you nice to meet
you good good good what's you up to what
are you guys doing I just came in
chopped it up with some people and
bounced it now I'm going to San
Francisco in a couple hours
what are you doing it's a bread starter
you trying to win a Super Bowl maybe by
the Jets win the Super Bowl
you give me any time like I said any
time thank you anything cuz it's crazy
because I think you should be doing more
activations for the content capture
exactly certain new flavor here for me
to tribe kick-start yes - here we go
as you guys know the old wine world I
know how to analyze averages very
Mountain Dewey in its flavor this
kickstart Mountain Dew original do
flavor so the do meanest makes sense I
can do some difference feel like I'm in
a [ __ ] commercial when you make it
pick the 39 that you're most excited
about and literally go like you know set
it up for like a minute or you know
first ten seconds I'm like we [ __ ]
crushed it was amazing and then one two
three four you know like even as you're
showing them
number three like that so that they can
really understand like yet exactly like
I want them to understand the level of
assets and then maybe even like a box of
like recommended segmentation yeah
exactly
[Music]
I got it out edit out I gotta go oh my
god how are you I am hi nice to meet you
I love your stuff Mike introduces the
job the guy that does a three-c hip-hop
that's outside laughs yeah can I get a
photo with hundred percent of me being
this do gotta do business eventually
just many time I gotta do it man thank
you so much take care buddy Thank You
Vicker heading to Napa foursome Shh hope
everybody's doing super well
Sunday afternoon vibes it is a 2:50 p.m.
here on the west coast
headed to the airport and here with a
Bobby Bevan Babb in life is the best
life is do you rock gonna meet us in the
airport at the airport here he's on the
way through so it's me you d rock me
whole crew Oh both of you're filming
because it's really oh by the way first
in line everybody who's on right now
message me right now on Facebook right
now message me on Facebook if you
haven't joined first in line by text
message and facebook messenger service 4
jabs and right hooks things like I'll
send the first in line in a couple hours
with the information of 7 to 8 a.m. in
LA to get my sneaker to be in the
lottery things of that nature giving I
give away 50 bucks so just say hi just
break first in line right now on
messenger you'll get an auto respond
back and and then and then you can fill
out the information and you will be in
the mix so join first in line if you're
not in first in line join first in line
the Geary be first in line system giving
away free schwag talk to a bunch of hot
brands doing a lot of contests the way
to get lunch and breakfasts with me one
hour view rocks time I gave away yes I'm
about to give away about Avenue into one
free hour consultation worth 5 to 10
thousand dollars with Bobby Bob Andy
rock on how to vlog and how to create
content at scale first lines would be
the greatest [ __ ] ever the facebook
messenger and text message platform that
I've just created the Geary be first in
line very easy to join when you're here
on Facebook live
because all you got to do is just hit
messenger just messaged me right now and
just why what's up what's up what's up
first in line hello first in line hello
first in line first line question mark
what's up get me out first in line I
want to be on first in line first in
line first in line first line FL FL
exhalation point FL FL FL open e FL life
FL space life however you want to reply
and start the conversation with me you
will get an automated response with the
form to fill out my first in line for
cylinders a lot I felt like that was the
Gucci my anger Jimin Jimin crystal and
Priscilla impersonal and Ursula
where's line first line first time for
Solange what up sack what up with Zack
what up Zack style girl no regret can't
regret not yet too young to regret too
young to have regrets right now regrets
are retro for the fourth quarter when
shit's almost finished way too young all
of you are way too young for of wrecks
right now right now if you're regretting
it if you're regretting and you're under
18 you're actually dwelling not
regretting your dwelling not regretting
see there's your moment
Jonny nd the books coming it's gonna
face the business put out content I put
out content vaynermedia puts a contact
we both put out content content content
content content the answer to every
question is more content more content
there's too much bad content there's
never too much good content like content
we and you don't know if you have good
content and you gotta let the market
decide so the answer for right now while
there's a lane grab is just more [ __ ]
content more content more concept
because 99% of people are just not
putting out enough content so I'm not
worried about the 1% that are so the the
answer is [ __ ] more content
[Music]
[Music]
you getting stuck I see feet in the mud
your weapon caught in the flood while
the water isn't water we run we push you
sold out harvesters us you have been
enjoying your life sippin the syrup and
a line in no way taking whatever you
touch the sword of the wicked is comes
with them done welcome